okay hello hello everyone how are you
this afternoon I hope you're not tired
because we got quite a lot to do so
let's actually begin what you can see in
the screen right now is a typical answer
for a pretty common sushar dotnet
interview question namely were stored
objects were stored value types and were
store reference types in dotnet platform
and typical answer is value types are on
the stack reference types are on the
heap you could say that you could answer
it in this way and this would be
probably right however throughout this
talk what we are going to do is we'll
discuss whether this question is
actually good whether it does make sense
to ask question like this and whether we
can bend the rules and somehow modify
the default allocator in dotnet and
allocate objects wherever we want so my
name is Adam Freeman ik and I'd like to
welcome you to this presentation and
invite you to the world of unsafe where
we are going to actually do a lot of
low-level nice tricks around the memory
allocation allocate objects on stack or
anywhere else implement custom data
structures performing better than least
of T distributed with dotnet and do some
more hijacking before we actually begin
few words about me I was a dot a
developer for over five years now I'm
more of a big data scholar machine
learning guy at Amazon I'm a blogger
public speaker feel free to drop me a
line on Twitter and take a look at my
blog this whole presentation is on my
blog also there are quite a few more
posts describing the things I'm going to
show you today so feel free to take a
look afterwards if you are interested ok
agenda of this talk so because what we
are going to do is will actually
implement custom memory allocation
mechanism in dotnet will allocate
reference types on the stack will
actually actually allocate objects
anywhere we like will hijack new
operator in dotnet to reroute the
allocation mechanism to use our own code
so in order to do all of these things
what we need to start with is the
details of how it works under the
so we'll take a look at the memory
structure up the allocation mechanisms
and primitives which are during dotnet
and we'll see some magical keywords
which are for instance not recognized by
resharper but still available in dotnet
since dotnet version 1 then what we are
going to do is we will see a lot of
demos showing what we are actually
modifying will see some mashing codes
some intermediate language as well will
debug some memory and work with windy
back and all of that just to allocate
objects using new operator and hijack
this operator to use it the way we would
like so let's begin we started with a
question where are objects stored in
dope net and if we take a look at the
dotnet Akama standard it actually does
not enforce that the reference types
must be stored on a heap it's typically
that they are stored on a heap but it
does not require that actually the
operating systems out there which do not
have heap at all so if we would like to
implement dotnet for those operating
systems we need to somehow either
implement the heap on our own or
actually go with stack allocation all
the way down also when it comes to value
types we know that they are stored on a
stack like by default however if a value
type is a part of a reference type like
integer is a field of a class it's
stored on heap as well
so generally value types can be stored
anywhere in dotnet and this is by design
the question is how can we allocate the
dotnet dotnet reference type on a stack
this is not something we can do by
default there were proposed add-ons to
Roslyn or to dotnet platform to be able
to allocate the objects on the stack
there is ongoing working dotnet core to
support escape analysis to move
reference types to the stack where it's
possible however as of now we cannot do
this by default but we are going to do
this in this talk so the thing about
standard is it does not require that the
reference types are allocated on a heap
so now the question is is asking that
where our value types or reference types
stored enough maybe we should instead
ask the question like where are they
stored in dotnet framework version this
in Windows version this on architecture
version this using pad version this blah
blah blah to specify which
implementation are we actually talking
about but then if we ask this question
during interview this is probably answer
will get because who cares why ever we
should ask spec all those specific
details about the platform you are using
because on one hand it's good to know
how it works under the hood on the other
hand it's not very very required in day
to day work especially in business lines
applications so this was just a
digression like university scientific
one let's now go to the internals
whenever we have a new object what we
used to say is when we have a line VAR o
equals new object we says we say that o
is our object and this is not true and
this talk we need to be a bit more
specific and we need to have this
differentiation between a reference and
an object the object is on the right
side of this equation VAR o is just a
reference pointing to the object so
objects are allocated on a heap but what
we hold in the variable o and the slide
is actually a managed pointer which
points to the object which points to the
object which on this slide is marked as
this rectangle in the middle this is our
object but o is just this pointer the
size of this pointer depends on the
architecture it can be 4 bytes 8 bytes
whatever else depending on the
architecture and the thing about the
object is that it stores the data only
the data no methods methods are stored
somewhere completely different and will
actually take a look later how methods
are stored in dotnet but with object
instances what we have we only have the
data so the fields describing the the
actual things we store in the objects
but there are two more things related
with with every object actually we know
there is a thing called reflection in
dotnet so we can ask the object hey
which type are you what are you
basically and
this works in runtime it's not compiled
time it's not during the compilation it
must be realized and performed when
running the application so every object
must have act tag which is called in
dotnet world actually like execution
engine class or type handle or runtime
type information just like here our TTI
there are multiple names explaining
exactly the same thing there is a tag
related to an object associated with the
object so the object knows what it is
and actually our reference is pointing
to the stack to this our TTI address and
on the right side of this slide what we
have is the description of the object
which we can use during runtime using
reflection to actually figure out all
the details of the object so which
methods it has which failed it has
properties interfaces inheritance
hierarchy everything else everything is
stored there so thanks to that in
runtime we can ask the object give me
your tag and then we can figure out the
type of this object we cannot do this
with value types because value types do
not have our TTI address they do not
have this execution engine class
associated so the only thing we know
about value types is this is just some
value we don't know the type one Maya
one might ask how it's actually possible
to call get type on value type in Dubna
done the answer is boxing whenever we
box a value type we actually have a
separate class describing this box
integer or box double or whatever else
but there is one more thing one more
thing with every object which we can see
actually here this is the sink blank
address which is one integer just before
the RTT eye of the object just before
the type of the object this thing is
used to store details about like hash
code or locking mechanisms or some
metadata of the object if they are pre
computed or if this data is too big is
just an address pointer to some other
metadata associated with this object
what is interesting here it's actually
before the object whenever we take a
look at the pointer
points to the middle of the object not
to the sink block the sink block is
effectively physically stored one
integer before the object so this is how
it works under the hood this is our
object what we are going to do is our
main goal for now is to allocate this
Fink on a stack we want to do this so we
need to now figure out what we want to
allocate on the stack so there are three
things we would like to allocate single
log address our TTI of the object and
all the fields it has those things we
need to allocate on a stack and then we
need to somehow grab a reference to this
object while it's on a stack and to do
this what we are going to do is we'll
use the key word which is unknown to
resharper and which is there since
dotnet one and namely it's make ref this
is an excerpt from MSD and documentation
what this keyword does it's actually a
bit tricky because what make Rev returns
is a typed reference which sounds very
similar to a reference but it's
completely different type of reference
is a reference to a reference so it's
pointer to pointer thanks to this
instruction we could get a pointer to
pointer to the object and find using
this pointer to pointer we can modify
the original reference to reroute it to
somewhere else there is also another
keyword which is called ref value which
does the opposite we give it the pointer
to the pointer to the object and it
returns as the reference to the object
which is effectively a pointer so those
things we are going to use and if I if
you are lost how it works under the hood
we were no more because there is yet
another pointer going on because we
cannot just use typed reference because
we have type safety what we need to do
is we need to get a pointer to a pointer
to a pointer to the object so we can
then call a treat it as an integer and
then modify everything else so once
again we have a new object we start on
the left side here new object this on a
heap somewhere it holds some value here
the peak that is 65 yes some value then
we have a reference normal c-sharp
reference nothing new here which we call
object o this is just a pointer which
has a value 5,000 because
points to the object which is stored at
the address 5,000 then we get a pointer
to the pointer to the object which is
typed reference which we get with
underscore underscore maker F this is
pointer with value 6000 as our reference
was at address 6000 pointing to the
others 5000 and speaking as fast as I
can just to make a lot of our confusion
here but then we get yet another pointer
so we get the pointer to the pointer to
the pointer to the object I hope you get
the idea I know it's a bit tricky but
with the code is getting much easier so
let's actually see the code but before
we see the code we would like to make
sure that okay we know what we are doing
and we are actually convinced that we
are doing what we want to do so few GC
facts garbage collector facts so there
are three generations in dotnet
framework I'll be using the.net
framework throughout this talk namely
generation zero one and two there is a
thing called large object heap which
stores object which are at least
eighty-five thousand bytes long so
either very big objects or like big
arrays etc also there is a very nice use
case 1000 array with 1000 doubles is
also stored in large or large object
heap like a fun fact and large of the
heap is an it is in generation 2 we are
going to use this fact to figure out
actually whether our objects are stored
where we want them to be allocated or
not and trivia for you just before we
actually go to the code is which
generation is a stack you probably know
you can call GC get generation and it
returns you with generation is this
object in the question is what is it
going to tell us when we ask for an
object which is stored in a stack let's
begin so first demo and what we are
going to do is we are going to cheat
just a little because we are not going
to allocate the object on a stack yet
what we are going to do is we'll just
copy the object to the stack later in
one of the later demos we'll be able to
allocate objects from scratch but as for
now we will just make it a little
simpler so let's begin we have this very
simple class poker which has one integer
field with one non virtual method called
right field with one v2
over write to string and with some
destructor yes nothing fancy here what
we want to do is we create a new object
here which is allocated on the heap is
that correct that that's correct
then we create another reference
pointing to the same object so we'll
have two references pointing to one
object on a heap then what we are going
to do is we'll allocate some memory on a
stack initialize it to bad food literal
just to be able to see this literal in
the debugger to see that we are looking
at the correct memory and then what we
are doing here is we are doing some
pointer magic just like I said what we
are doing here is we start with with our
hip poker this is a pointer to an object
then we get the pointer to this pointer
using my craft so now we have pointer to
the pointer to the object then what we
do is we get address of this effectively
getting yet another pointer so pointer
to the pointer to the pointer to the
object now what we can do is we can cast
those things two pointers to integers
just to trick the compiler so type
safety is that we can just compile this
code it doesn't scream about wrong types
here so we just the reference those cuss
to integer pointers etc we subtract for
that's because I told you the sink block
is before the object and it's one
integer which on my platform because I'm
compiling this on any CPU is four bytes
long so we need to subtract four bytes
and then we have a pointer which
actually points to the very beginning of
the object and then we print things like
the RTT I address and some other things
and we just wait here in red line so
let's start it so it printed out
something and what we are going to do
right now is we will launch in debug
attach to the process for those of you
who are not familiar with this tool in
Windows there is the bugging engine
installed directly in the operating
system you don't need to install
anything and as
especially with Visual Studio is not
installing anything for you just to make
the debugging possible it's possible
they're always what you need to do to be
able to debug something is you need to
have some form of an interface on top of
this debugging engine Visual Studio is
one interface there are many more for
instance there is dotnet spy there is
windy bug there are some console
debuggers things which you can use just
to start your debugging session the
thing is why am I using windy bug
instead of Visual Studio is that there
is an extension distributed with dotnet
framework which is called sauce which is
son of strike this extension is able to
read them raw byte structure in the of
your application and show it to you
something which you could do in Visual
Studio I think until 2012 which is not
possible anymore so what I'm doing is
I'm using exactly the same debugging
engine which you are using with Visual
Studio is just some different UI because
I'm using some different extensions to
Danny ng so first thing I'm going to do
is I'm loading the plug-in the source
allowing me to read the memory then I
change the change my fret and then what
I'm going to do is actually I want to
dump the whole stack and everything
there let's make this hopefully a bit
bigger but Ike yeah now now a bit better
is this readable at the end yep cool
okay what we got here is I started this
application and we are now in this line
console red line so what we can see here
is yes we do have our call stack this is
program main this is a red line red line
if we scroll to the right we should
actually no we do not see the lines here
we do not but we okay let's just assume
that I'm telling you the truth
but you can see that red line is here so
it looks like this is correct so what I
have here is all the objects everything
which is there in memory and you can see
things here which are allocated so I
have heap poker and I do have original
poker so I do have those two variables
those two reference is pointing to the
same object and as you can see here
addresses here are the same because they
point to the same object
so what I can do right now I can just
dump this object and you can see that it
has one filled with value which is given
here which is value five so you can see
exactly the same thing I allocated here
so we do have value five and also you
can see the address of this object is
here and the method table so our TTI
address is here so our TTI ends with D
before and object is 8 3 8 if we now go
here and take a look at the output of
our application we can see that a method
and value is exactly the same yes this
pointer may be four bytes earlier just
because of the same book but we are
actually looking at the correct data so
what we want to do now is we want to
copy this object to the stack let's see
our stuck here when I dump the address
of our stack frame you can see 10 bad
food literals I told you we are
allocating some bad food on a stack just
to see this memory in the bugger this is
what we are looking at so so far so good
let's carry on so I just resumed this
application and hit enter and what our
application is now doing is it's going
to copy the object to the stack so what
it does it uses this magical pecados
variable so we read the bytes we print
them out and we allocate them in this
array which we allocated on the stack so
we are just copying free integers why
free integers one sink block were one
our TDI address and one field of the
object which is just the only integer we
have in our pocket class which is here
so we are copying free integers to the
stack and now we can since we have done
it already what we can do is we can
break in D in the application in our
debugger and try to dump the stack again
and this time you see that free bad food
retailer literals are gone now we copied
free values and oddly enough this thing
is exactly the thing we saw in the
output this is our our TDI address so
now we have a proper object on a stack
those three integers are the object what
we now want to do is we need to grab a
reference to this object so we
can use this normally so we resume our
application again we hit enter here at
what we are doing in this line yep in
this line we set the reference which was
originally there so it points to the
address which is inside the array stored
on the stack how it works we do have our
type addres Firenze
which we created using make ref so we
just need to get this pointer to pointer
to pointer to you to object but instead
of going all the indirection levels we
just need to go from pointer to the
pointer to the pointer to the pointer
and modify dead one value because this
is reference pointing to the heap
we will just reroute it to the stack so
believe it or not this is what we are
actually doing here with this magical
pointer operations what we can do now is
we can break again and what we would
like to do we would like to change the
fret again and dump the stuck with all
the variables again and now what we see
here those two value are different
because our original pocket still points
to the heap but our hip pocket let me
yep our hip poker is very close to this
value and this value is actually the
beginning of our stack frame in this
method so we modified this one reference
and now we have a reference pointing to
the object on stack so we can resume our
application and actually what we could
do as well is we can create a stack
poker using this array value keyword
which is redundant here we don't need to
create a new reference but if you would
like to go with Rev value this is the
way to go so now what we would like to
do is we have our object on the stack we
would like this object to be normal
ordinary object working the same way as
the object on the heap so what we would
like it to be able to do we would like
to be able to read and write fields to
call study a virtual non virtual methods
we would like it to be to be we could we
would like to lock it lock the objects
so use the sync block correctly as well
so now we are just testing whether
things work here so what we do is we
just print the field and we call nan
view to our method from the original
paka in the stack pecan so let me just
hit enter here sorry
nollie devalue was five we copied the
value to the stack we can see 5 here 5
there then one me modify those fields on
the heap on the high on the stack two
three five three fours we print them out
again it's exactly the same and to
convince you even more that this object
is on the stack
we can modify it just by modifying
values in this array of integers which
was allocated on the stack so we know
this field is at the index two we modify
this field and yes the object was
modified then we would like to actually
be able to call view to our methods
which is to string here so we just go to
string and to string in my
implementation is very simple because it
just returns field to string so whenever
we do this we should actually see the
same at the same field again so we have
three five three three times free then
we display object types just to make
sure that the RTT eye reflection
everything around works correctly and we
can see make ref Paco this is my poker
class so it's the same and ultimately we
would like our locking to work correctly
so we would like to be able to modify
sink block so I have two tasks one of
them will lock a lock stack Paco then
other tasks will try to log the same
object but there will be some time out
here for two seconds so when I hit enter
here oh sorry I just missed generation
answering the trivia where is stack
stack is in generation 2 why is that
because it's implementation detail that
whatever address doclet checks the
addresses if the address is in
generation 0 actually dotnet tries to
check the boundaries it knows where the
generation 0 is so it's checked that
checks the boundaries because the object
is not in generation 0 it checks the
boundaries for generation 1 since the
object is not in generation 1 by default
it must be in generation 2 we just only
hack this a little bit so it's actually
like a side-effect not something they
explicitly encoded but this is how it
works and returning to this locking so I
hit enter again and you can see that I'm
taking some logs and then after 2
seconds locks are released taken again
etc so it looks like the object war
correctly and ultimately what we could
do is we could just register the object
or finalization so it's cleanup by the
garbage collector I'm not doing this
here because this thing crashes pretty
often as we are releasing object which
is on the stack so the stack may not be
available there so let's just recompile
this and see how it goes this time last
time it unfortunately crashed sometimes
so hopefully this time it works again so
let's just few seconds until it compiles
with this visual studio working in
virtual machine which makes it even
slower than typically and let's go
through this application again
so now logs and we hit enter no this
time it did not crash so you can see
that garbage collector actually called
the destructor and the object was
cleaned up but generally you should not
be doing this as this may crash your
application cool so raise your hands if
you are convinced we allocated the
object on stack yes I can see some hands
in the air cool because right now what
we are going to do is we are going to do
even more fancy think so generally you
know how list of T works in dotnet it
works not by storing the objects it
stores the references so in C++ world it
would be something like vector of short
pointers or whatever pointers are now
fashionable there but it just stores the
references so whenever we would like to
iterate through these objects so with
what we do is we go to reference object
reference object reference object so we
have this ping-pong style what we are
going to do is we'll implement list
which stores the object inside its
content
so when iterating through the list will
not do the ping-pong will just go object
object object linearly the working
hypothesis here is if we allocate
objects next to each other during
iteration we should do it faster than
list of T why because of CPU caches etc
etc so let's actually see what we are
doing and how it works so let me just
close this demo open yet another one
okay and I'll started in the bagra
and this explained you what it does so
we have a poker class with 16 integers
and what we are going to do is we'll
test free collections are a list of T
and our unsaved list so for each test we
actually generate a poker with some
values which are dependent which depend
on the iteration and then when testing
array in this example we create an array
of objects we create pocos allocate them
we measure this with stopwatch and print
the insertion time at the end we reset
the stopwatch and then with iterate of
our objects and calculate the sum of all
the fields and then stop the stopwatch
print the result print the time we do
the same for a list of T we pre
allocated the list with the elements so
we do not spend time or reallocating the
list and ultimately we do the same with
unsaved list and my test is being run
three times for each collection with
twenty million elements even though it
says debug here is running in release
just this one project and also since
this is running in virtual machine
results might be a little skewed but you
can find in my blog a post actually
measuring this with benchmark dotnet and
confirming that this tends to be faster
in some cases and Fillmore thinks about
unsafe least what we do here is we have
an array of integers which we use for
storing our objects so we need to accept
the the array the size of the array how
many elements we would like to allocate
and how big every element is and then
when adding we do the same magic with my
craft pointers to pointers to pointers
copy things and then we also prepare a
reference pointing to this object and we
store it in our array helper array here
so we do not need to recalculate this
reference every time when we try to
access the object so what we are going
what we have as a result so you can see
that first we are going with array
insertion time is something between 4 &
8 generally this is typically around 4
and 1/2 second iteration time is around
200 milliseconds typically here it's a
little lower apparently for at least we
can see that least
very similar results around four seconds
but what we can see for unsaved list is
that insertion is almost three times
faster so first and also iteration is
very similar to two lists of T and to a
normal array so what we can see is our
working hypothesis was not confirmed
iteration was not faster with our
unsaved list but insertion was faster
which is actually very interesting since
now instead of storing just one
reference when adding an object to a
list what we do is we copy like 60
something bytes to the list and still
it's much faster so I encourage you to
run experiment on your machines to
confirm those results or see that they
are different
actually this demo is based on a demo
which was created in Java world there
was a blogger who implemented a very
similar thing in JVM because in JVM you
also can a allocate memory the way you
like anywhere you like and there this
working hypothesis that iteration
through object is faster was confirmed
then there the guy got results showing
that iterating is faster whereas adding
items to a list is much slower here I
get some different results so this is
actually interesting if you are
interested how it works under the hood
you can D compile the code and see some
machine code like this to figure out
whether there is a vectorization or
whatever else but we can skip this amid
this for now so that was demo number 2
so in first demo we allocated object on
a stack what we actually did even though
we did not emphasize this is we
allocated the object anywhere we wanted
anywhere it is not that we need to
allocate it on a stack we can allocate
it anywhere we like so in demo tool we
use this to implement this list now the
next step is actually to implement a
full-blown normal memory allocator
in.net this is the thing which we are
going to do now so what we are going to
do is let me just close things here
and let me just set a start up yet
another demo and run it so I told you in
first demo that we allocate object on a
stack which was not true actually we
were just copying the object to the
stack what we would like to do is we
would like to be able to create this
object from scratch and also have some
compiler support when doing that yes we
do not want to run in this unsafe world
constantly so what I would like to do is
whenever I have this object showing all
the possible things primitives in am set
cetera et cetera
I would like to allocate it in this way
because I cannot just call new object
and pass the constructor parameters
because I don't use new in my case what
I would like to do is I suggest we can
use an expression here instead of
creating this object and then copying it
we just described how to create the
object using expression of func of the
tab we would like to allocate and then
pass all the parameters here thanks to
that we can later examine this
expression evaluate all the arguments
and allocate the objects the way we
would like so what we are actually doing
here just showing you that this object
is created and it has all the values and
we can also deallocate it using by
calling our allocator explicitly the
only thing which we didn't know in demo
one is how big the object is and what is
the RTT eye what is the type handle of
this object so what we are actually
doing in our allocator to get a type
handle to get our TTI address this is
actually pretty easy we can just go with
reflection get type and hood value and
this is it
so we want to allocate this object and
now we have the type handle so we know
how to allocate the type of this object
but to get the object size what we need
to do is we actually need to rely on
some details of how the objects have the
metadata is stored under the hood so if
you D compile the code or go with
debugger you can actually see that the
size of the object is stored around here
so you just get the type
kondou which is pointer to the metadata
of the object you need to read word
integer which is which is four or eight
bytes after the beginning and this is
your size this is just the integer so we
do this and then what we do is we can
implement the allocator any way we we
like any way we are used to like when
writing in C so we can go with simple
implementation of free lists so we get
just a get a free chunk of the memory
then we allocate this chunk if we don't
have a variable memory right now we
create a new object we remove it from
calling the destructor just to be a
little safer
we also pin the object so it's not moved
by the garbage collector otherwise our
references would be broken and we store
the chunks etc etc the last thing which
we need to do is we would like to call a
constructor yes how to do it so actually
to call a constructor let me just figure
out where the constructor is hold we can
go two ways either we go with reflection
actually you can call a constructor for
an object multiple times with reflection
you can also create objects without
calling a constructor that's like
another digression so either we go with
reflection or we can go with with a code
calling the constructor but generating
intermediate language code yes so what
we do is we create a dynamic method we
emit we get IO generator we emit all the
opcodes to actually evaluate the
arguments if the arguments are value
type we need to unbox them and then we
just call the constructor and we return
the object that's all we need to do and
this actually works under the hood and
we can create allocate the object
anywhere we like and play with any
allocator implementations we would like
yes so we can go with free lists or with
a different allocation policies like
best bet or or lowest chunk etc etc
that's it that's it when it comes to
demo number three so now we can see that
we have a full-blown allocator so we are
happy now
but there is just one thing which really
irritates us we need to write this
expression tree we need to pass this
lambda to create the object what we
would like to do actually is we would
like to say new something and get this
something allocated the way we like and
in the place we like
so let's actually see what does this new
operator do adults under the hood so
when you go to documentation what you
can see here is that new object which is
actually instruction code by the new
operator in c-sharp it allocates a new
instance of the class associated with
constructor constructor here is actually
a type handle which we pass so we pass
the type describing what we want to
allocate and then it's used to create
the object and call it constructor it
also initializes all the fields to 0 etc
and calls the constructor the proper
constructor so what we have is exactly
the same what we did in demo number 3 we
had a some free chunk of memory which
was zeroed somewhere somewhere before
getting it so we create we allocated the
type handle of the object so we store
the type of our instance which we are
allocating we call the constructor and
then we return the reference to this
object so it happens that we are
actually doing exactly the same thing as
the new object instruction is doing
under the hood so the last missing bit
here is how to convince new object to
call our code instead of allocating
memory it used to do so before getting
to all those things we will do it
manually so let me just prepare our my
last demo and set it as start a project
what we are going to do here is we will
use the allocator we wrote in previous
demo and what we are going to do is
first we allocate the object using this
a locator just to make sure that the
object is in generation 2 so we know its
allocated by this a locator not by the
normal new thing and its allocated in
the place we would like
to be then we create new object just
normal ordinary new object we hijack new
operator and we allocate yet another
object the expected output of this when
we print out all the generations for the
objects is when we run this first a
locator should be in generation zero
because this is in line one six seven
this is just a normal object allocated
in generation zero yes then we allocate
object using our a locator this object
should go to generation - then we
allocate to normal objects using new
operator first of them should be
allocated in generation zero and Dia the
latter should be allocated in generation
two after we hijack the the new operator
since the hijacking is committed out
here both of them are allocated in
generation zero right now but what we
can do if we uncomment this fink and
recompile this discard the difference
right now should be actually in this
line because when we now hijack the new
operator you can see that the last
object is allocated by our a locator in
generation 2 and the only thing we did
was hijacking the new operator let's
comment this out and do this by hand so
let me start this up and recompile this
application and start it again it's now
waiting in this red line in this line
just before allocating last object what
we are going to do is we are going to
use win debug again to see actually what
happens under the hood so first let
let's load sauce and then what we would
like to do is I would like to decompile
this main method to see what mashing
code is running under the hood what is
happening there so I do have a cheat
sheet here to copy the commands to
actually find the the object where it is
or actually the metadata of this method
so what it prints out here it shows that
the method is in this assembly this
module the method name is programmed at
main and the treated code of the of this
method is here so let's now D compile
this code and you can see
this is normal mashing code no assembly
no see no intermediate language what we
are doing here is we are looking at the
normal machine code robots so what we
want to do is we would like to see what
is happening in this line yes in line
171 we do have lines printed out here so
we can see that line one seven one is
compiled to this part and this part
because it's not very readable I will
show it to you using slides so what we
do here is we are actually doing the
things which new object documentation
told us to do so first we store a we
move to ECX address we move there the
type of the object we would like to
allocate this is this constructor which
was mentioned by the documentation and
then what we do is we call dotnet helper
code Corinne for help news fast here
when we get the output which is returned
to us in EAX register we just store it
somewhere and then we call the
constructor of this object yes so
calling the constructor is this part
allocating is the first two lines so
what we would like to do here is when we
go back to our our code what we would
like to do is we would like to get this
address and see what it does under the
hood I will show you this code once
again on the slides but before that
let's just write this address as dotnet
a locator method so we know where it was
so let's go back to slides when we do
compile this code what it does it just
does the exactly the same things as we
did in them free so first it just gets
the free chunk of memory and checks how
many bytes they are still available in
this chunk of memory so it gets the
object size when you imagine a chunk of
memory there is a pointer pointing
somewhere in the middle saying that I
used this beginning of this chunk and
this part of this chunk is still
available to me so I just get this
pointer added the size and then I check
whether I moved out of this chunk or not
if I did not then I can just
it means that the object fits here it
can be allocated here so what we
actually do is we do some bookkeeping we
update the pointer to the to the last
byte allocated we calculate the
beginning address of the object and we
just return it but if we jumped out of
this free chunk then we actually need to
call the last line here which is JIT
underscore new which is like a proper
method going to operating system hey I
need some more memory please give me a
setter etcetera and then allocate the
object what we would like to do is we
would like to replace this first part of
this method and instead of allocating it
in the chunks with dotnet knows about we
would like to allocate them using our a
locator so let's go to the code and
oddly enough you may say actually I do
have a method which is very similar to
the method with dotnet calls very
similar in terms of method signature how
we were calling the method in dotnet if
you take a look here is we just pass one
parameter through ECX address this is
the type of the object we would like to
allocate so you can see that I have a
method which is static and accepts
exactly one parameter
why is it static how many parameters
would this method have if it was not
static - because it would get implicit
this pointer because we are not we do
not want this parameter it's static so
we get one pointer and we return exactly
one pointer so the signature matches the
method we would like to do what we do
next is we just get the object size etc
do some magic with a microp with
pointers we allocate this object and we
are done so the thing is how to convince
dotnet to call this method instead of
the original one and we can do this by
modifying the machine code so what we
need to do is let's figure out where our
method is in the memory so if I run this
command what you can see is that my
allocate method is at this address if I
now dump this method you can see it has
lines around 89 91
so if we go to 89 it's actually here
yeah this is the method which we are
looking at right now so we can also see
that this is our method for allocation
what we can do right now let's modify
the original method let's modify the
dotnet method so I am now in the mashing
code modification mode and what I want
to do is I would like to modify first
line of the dotnet method and do jump
sorry for that let me make this a little
bigger would what I would like to do is
I would like to do the jump to our
method so I modify the code
sorry for that syntax error and now I
exited this mode and my application
probably crashed I need to enter this
modification mode again modify it with
this address and I'm good I'm done
let's now decompile the dotnet method
again just to make sure that we modified
it correctly and yes if we now take a
look at this code which we marked as the
dotnet method we can see the jump is
here and we are jumping to address 0
which is here so it looks like we are
all good as something I did not make any
typos here etc when I now hit enter in
this you can see that yes in fact we
allocated this object in generation 2
what we did is we just jumped from the
dotnet code to our allocator return the
object and we are good to go this is how
we did it but we did it manually let's
now do this automatically so what I'm
going to do is I am actually going to
uncomment this line around this
application and it's still waiting in
this read line read line line yes what I
would like to do is I would like to
attach to this process to generic unsafe
a lock and what I would like to do is I
want to show you that hey this actually
works the way I explained you so I'm
hitting a I'm hitting I'm hitting what
hitting enter here we are now in this
line new object I add a breakpoint here
to go to this console.writeline
and I also write a other breakpoint here
if the method if the operator was not
hijacked we will just go to line 179 yes
so now I hit continue and we are in our
allocated method we can also see with
our code stack call stack that we came
from new object to our method here but
that's not enough if I hit continue
again I add breakpoint here to the next
console I'd line method execution when I
hit continue we are in a row allocate
again why is that because in this line
we are actually concatenating some
strings so we do allocate new object so
all the allocated objects are actually
going through our a locator so when I
hit continue few more times you can
actually see that I'm still in this in
our allocate method and there is some
external code here because I do have
enabled just my code so it's not showing
me the dotnet internals under the hood
so it looks like it's working now the
question is how it works
and the hijack part is actually pretty
easy we do the same things we did
manually so we have a very simple method
which is not in lined by the
just-in-time compiler we just creates a
new object what I do next is I get the
method of the address of this method I
just compile it so it's available and
then I know where the call to the dot
net method is actually inside the
machine code so I know the offset this
code is prepared just for my
architecture and debug and release mode
if you would like to use this in
different architectures like 64-bit
architecture IEM architecture etc you
need to add some if and if here just to
make it just to support more more more
architectures what we do next is because
we know the address of the dotnet method
we know the address of our method what
we actually need to do is when we return
the address we need to generate a piece
of machine code this is one level lower
than the assembly code because we need
to also take care of
which jump instruction we are actually
using so we generate few bytes actually
performing the jump the relative short
jump with this offset with these
addresses we store those bytes in memory
modifying the original dotnet method and
we're good to go and having said all of
that that would be actually it there is
a QR code pointing to my blog serious
explaining all those things you can also
find those slides there so if you want
feel free to just scan this code
there are also some some more posts
explaining how to actually implement a
locator which works by allocating on a
stack using fod and rewriting the
assembly code under the hood and a lot
of more interesting things about mario
memory management dotnet internals etc
etc questions do you have any questions
here was first question please
cool the question is how does the new
span in dotnet core fit here actually
what I did is you can do very similar
things with span and it looks like span
is exactly the same things I'm doing
here but they are just safe compiler
knows what you are trying to do so it
tries to stop you when you break things
because I'm just generating mashing code
like by hand this is unsafe as the title
suggests it can crash and actually when
preparing those demos it crashed pretty
often it's only now which is working
nice but with span you get the
advantages of what I shown here but you
have much better time say a type safety
so actually very similar ideas and also
I believe here here this last link on
this slide is pointing to a rosaline
stack a lock proposal which was there
like four years ago which was actually
trying to do what I did just
automatically by the compiler
so generally those things align you only
get better type safety
another question yes gathered so the
question is basically where would we
like to use this so it's say if it does
not crush and it's actually better it is
used a lot and actually it's connected
related to the span of two things in
game development in image processing in
video streaming etc in those areas you
pretty often need to actually go and
read the memory directly using pointers
to not copy bytes here and there to do
that previously you had to use things
like this
actually one Maya one might ask why even
bother with this microwave was this
keyword do what is this keyword doing in
dotnet at all before we had generics
whenever you passed a value type to a
method which was supposed to accept
anything you get boxing so to avoid the
boxing you could go with typed
references to read the objects directly
since we have generics right now we do
not have boxing this use case is not
like very common anymore but also at
that time it was exactly the same you
wanted to get some performance boost
just just by avoiding copying of the
memory here and there this is the same
with spam you can use span to read the
memory directly it's only slightly
better because of type safety so
wherever you actually want to process
some data wafer and avoided redundant
copies there it's actually a place for
those things and there they are actually
used I know there is a one big company
working on some queueing system which is
using things like that to manage the
memory directly and to allocate objects
directly so yeah this is not something
which is not used at all probably when
you use this you may want to go with C++
and
soompi invokes but if you want to stick
with c-sharp you can do this easily with
just unsafe and pointers etc any more
questions yes
which part exactly cool what we did in
demo one is we just copied the object if
you would use the same you would do the
shallow copy not the big copy shallow
copy would it work if some other code
would allocate objects yes because we
modified the new allocation mechanism it
would work would the garbage collector
clean up the objects properly if you
have nested objects some of them
allocated by dotnet some of them
allocated by you this probably would not
work because I'm just freeing only the
objects I allocated but for all the
other objects GC should clean them up at
the right moment sometimes in the future
so I would generally say like 95 percent
it should work I did not test this
extensively it may be crushing it some
scenarios but generally yes this should
work any more questions if there are no
more questions feel free to I'll be
wandering around here so you can talk to
me after this after this talk and some
more references for you if you are
interested in dotnet internals of any
type those are books which I highly
recommend reading starting with going
from top to bottom like from the highest
low level to the lowest low level you
can start with CLR via c-sharp it's like
you could say alimentary book about low
level and then actually what you need to
do is read more and more about Windows
operating system internals so Windows
via C Spillers plus Windows internals
etc if you want to know how to use wind
debug how to either read the memory I
did throughout this talk or how to track
memory leaks or a deadlocks etc in debug
is a great tool for doing that
there are two books by Mario Hubert and
I think there are also two Pluralsight
courses with the same titles namely
advanced Windows debugging and advanced
dotnet debugging if you would like to go
with like customizing the dotnet I mean
changed their way how it allocates the
memory how it creates the Fred etc etc
you can do this by by modifying the shim
which creates dotnet a dotnet process
for you and this is nicely described as
customizing the Microsoft CLR if you are
also interested in like dotnet internals
of memory structure of how it manages
the memory etc everything around that
there are two nice books shirts or CLI
which describes the project rotor which
is actually open-source dotnet ten years
ago for research purposes and also book
of the run time if you're interested in
all the memory under the hood expert
dotnet ill assembler great book
explaining all the single bits of memory
and generally if you like those
low-level things maybe just to read
about them not necessarily use in your
applications great blog the old new
thing where the when Raymond Chen
explains all the architectures debugging
etc if you're interested in things I did
throughout this talk here are some links
pointing to to allocators to hijacking
new hijacking any functions in dotnet
etc or running machine codes and if you
are finally interested just waiting for
some before few people to capture their
photos and if you are interested in like
the allocation which I told you
generally there's some nice materials as
well like debugging demos or dotnet
memory structure or playing with unsafe
in JVM this is actually the unsafe least
in JVM world which I mentioned make Rev
stack a lock etc all those things just
as I said those slides are on my blog so
you can find them there and yeah I think
that would be it having said all of that
I think it's time to call it the day my
name is Adam full moon egg and I'd like
to thank you for attending this talk I
hope you enjoyed it thank you
you
[Applause]